when my little brother Lucas was born my
parents would think that he went walk or
talk and the doctors even said he might
not make it to his tenth birthday
but today a few months away from his
tenth birthday we're doing our 15th
triathlon together
my name is Noah Aldridge and this is my
brother Lucas Aldridge I guess I'm
talking Noah is 11 and Lucas is 9 and
Lucas was born with a rare genetic
neurologic condition called listen
zeppeli he's unable to walk unable to
talk he's unable to feed himself but
despite all of his challenges the
happiest little boy that you ever meet
about four years ago our boys started
doing triathlons together in most cases
that wouldn't be a big deal a lot of
kids do triathlons but there's something
very special about the way our boys do
triathlons I pull Lucas in a raft
pressroom ocean then I pull him in a
bike cart during their bike and I push
him in a running cart during the run I
wanted to do this because Lucas can't do
things like weekend he can't really play
sport so this is something we could do
together currently we're training for
our 15th try a thon which is this
weekend before the race I always feel
nervous I don't think I'll ever get over
that I just don't want to hurt Lucas I
don't care if I win the race he just has
to be okay
[Music]
before the race Lukas gets serious and
he gets his race face on and they're
ready to compete they swim around 200
yards then they transition to a bike
they'll go usually about three to five
miles and then they'll run about a mile
NOAA's strong physically an especially
mentally because he's truly only doing
these races for his brother sometimes I
feel like that Scot be over soon right
but I just hear Lucas that's how he says
go faster every day is precious with
that little boy I try to soak in the
experience because we don't know how
long the boys will be able to triathlons
together any one of them could be their
last what these boys accomplish gives me
immense sense of pride knowing Lucas for
an inspiration people see these two
young boys and that gives them hope and
it gives them encouragement to go out
and tackle life challenges
[Music]
you